y
bienvenidos a la entrevista hoy desde
glasgow en escocia nos acompaña a la
presidenta de la cob 25 y la ministra
del medioambiente de chile carolina
schmidt gracias por acompañarnos en
france24 muchas gracias está contigo
aquí en glasgow justamente dando inicio
a la con 26 ministra chile ha entregado
hoy oficialmente al reino unido- la
responsabilidad la gran responsabilidad
de salvar el planeta cuál cree usted es
esa primera acción que debe adoptar el
mundo y los líderes que se van a reunir
las próximas horas aquí en glasgow bueno
sin lugar a duda la primera acción que
se tiene que tomar es cumplir el acuerdo
de parís el mundo ya se puso de acuerdo
de cómo operar para enfrentar el cambio
climático y el acuerdo de parís
establece tres medidas muy concretas
para hacerlo los países deben presentar
su gene de cee que son sus compromisos
de reducción de emisiones tiene que
presentar sus estrategias climáticas que
son la ruta verdad con todas las medidas
para lograrlo y tercero tienen que
estaban comprometidos a entregar un
financiamiento
100.000 millones de dólares para la
acción climática para los países en vías
de desarrollo sin embargo el llamado hoy
día es a todos pero particularmente a
los países del g20 para que cumplan
justamente estas medidas establecidas en
el acuerdo de parís no tenemos que
reescribir el acuerdo de parís lo que
tenemos que hacer es cumplirlo y ese es
la medida que esperamos para combatir la
acción y cambio climático es simple pero
difícil cómo cumplir el acuerdo de parís
cómo lograr controlar la temperatura del
planeta a 1.5 grados
bueno el aporte más significativo que
hizo la cob 25 fue el consenso alcanzado
en esta para que la ciencia a la base de
todas las decisiones climáticas la
ciencia no negociable no es negociable
la ciencia y la ciencia ha sido clara el
último informe del ipcc así lo demuestra
la única manera de mantener el
incremento de la temperatura por bajo
los 1,5 grados es siendo el mundo
carbono neutral a más tardar el año 2050
y eso nos habla de una cantidad total de
emisiones de carbono que podemos
realizar todas las actividades que
realizamos verdad generalmente producen
carbono sabemos gracias a la ciencia
cuánto es lo máximo que podemos emitir
para evitar que la temperatura supere
los 1,5 grados esa es la gran guía eso
es lo que tenemos que escuchar y las
medidas adoptar tiene que cumplir con
eso que señalaba la ciencia por supuesto
estamos todos en mora de hacer algo no
solamente los gobiernos sino desde las
casas ministra cuál es su balance de su
presidencia de la presidencia de la con
25 su gran logro y lo que quedó
pendiente bueno este más importante
chile asumió la presidencia de la cop de
américa latina y el caribe la cob 25 el
momento muy complejo cuando grandes
emisores como eeuu se bajaba del acuerdo
de parís y brasil que no solamente gran
emisor de américa latina y el caribe
también renunciaba a ser la presidencia
en este momento chile tuvo el coraje de
dar un paso adelante y asumir esta
presidencia de la cob entregando un
balance y dio donde los mayores logros
tienen que ver primero con la
incorporación de la ciencia segundo con
haber extendido la acción climática como
un pilar en los océanos se cubren dos
tercios de nuestro planeta tercero
entendiendo que el proceso de
transformación que se requiere para
enfrentar el cambio climático es
multisectorial por lo tanto requiere la
transformación de la economía del
transporte del sistema energético del
sistema agricultura y por lo tanto
incorporando los a todos nuestros osos y
cuarto relevando la adaptación al mismo
nivel que la mitigación que es
justamente lo que necesitamos hacer dado
que las familias en el mundo entero
estamos sufriendo los efectos del
calentamiento global hoy con los
aumentos de la temperatura con los
huracanes con las grandes sequías que
estamos viviendo que es lo que queda
pendiente bueno lo que queda pendiente
ahora es poder implementar el acuerdo de
país en plenitud para poder generar la
medida verdad que nos permitan dar
cumplimiento a este objetivo y para eso
los pendientes son el llamado particular
a los países del g20 a cumplir lo
establecido en el acuerdo de país
presentar sus compromisos de reducción
de emisiones presentar las estrategias
climáticas que estemos está en el camino
de cómo lograrlo y lograr no solamente
superar este déficit de financiamiento
que no han cumplido verdad a los países
en vías de desarrollo sino que
establecer además un set de reglas
claras que no permita plenamente la
implementación del acuerdo ministra cómo
lograr ese objetivo de lograr cero
carbono para el 2050 si no hemos visto
un compromiso o por lo menos no estarán
aquí para la foto de los líderes china y
grandes emisores como rusia también más
allá de las personas que vengan más allá
de los discursos bonitos que se pueden
hacer la forma de lograrlo es
presentando los países esos acuerdos
concretos con sus planes y sus medidas
específicas en ese aspecto de la cob 26
tiene tres desafíos muy importantes
ambición y la ambición se llena con
cuando los países presenten sus dns y su
estrategia financiamiento que los países
cumplan con los 100 mil millones que
estaban comprometidos y tengamos
establecida una nueva meta de
movilización de recursos financieros
y
2025 y tercero estableciendo especies de
reglas claras entendiendo que esta
transformación
multisectorial que requerimos para un
desarrollo limpio requiere de reglas
claras para la aplicación del mercado de
carbono para tener un set de
transparencia que nos permita ser
creíble no solamente decir la voluntad
que tenemos de cambiar sino que como se
monitorea verdad de manera creíble para
todos de esa reducción de emisiones que
estamos señalando durante dos semanas el
reino unido debe liderar esas acciones
que debe tomar el mundo pero sin embargo
se percibe un ambiente agridulce también
el primer ministro británico y el
presidente de la con 26 han advertido
que posiblemente no se van a lograr esos
objetivos que puede sucederle el planeta
si no se logra eso yo soy positiva
porque entendemos que los procesos
multilaterales
requiere en verdad de tiempo no son no
son fáciles no son rápidos pero los
consensos son fundamentales para poder
enfrentar problemas que son globales
ningún país por mucho por la voluntad
que tenga va a poder resolver esto de
manera aislada lo tanto el gran desafío
es sumar voluntades en esta
transformación
multisectorial y entendiendo que esto no
es algo solo de los estados los actores
no estatales juegan un rol fundamental
la transformación del sector privado la
empresa como motor de la innovación y el
desarrollo que necesitamos para esa
transformación hoy día tenemos las
tecnologías que nos hacen ver
oficiosamente verdad hacer esta
transformación el hidrógeno verde el
fuerte desarrollo de las energías
limpias nos permiten mirar positivamente
esta transformación es posible la
participación de los gobiernos locales
qué son los que aplican en los
territorios no solamente las medidas de
cambio a las energías limpias sino que
también las medidas de adaptación al
cambio climático que es la mayor
urgencia que requiere la familia en todo
el mundo hoy para que los impactos del
cambio climático no las afecten tan
severamente y tercero por supuesto que
tenemos que tener entendido que la
academia del mundo científico es la base
de esto y un sistema financiero que
responda la buena noticia es que hoy
tenemos una movilización del sector
privado
muy fuerte uno de los aportes de la cob
25 fue haber renovado el
partnership de barack que establece la
participación de los actores no
estatales y a través de los champion de
chile verdad hideyuki haber movilizado
ya a más de 7000 instituciones
organizaciones y más de 90 trillones de
dólares comprometidos con la carbono
neutralidad al año 2050 esta
transformación
esa es la velocidad de los cambios que
necesitamos y si justamente sumamos
trabajamos juntos en eso si podemos
lograr los objetivos que nos planteamos
usted resalta que no solamente es el
trabajo de los gobiernos las políticas
públicas pero también de la población
civil de las organizaciones como cada
uno desde nuestras casas a nuestra
audiencia mundial puede empezar a
aportar algo para para justamente
reducir esos riesgos de catástrofe que
puede vivir el planeta bueno eso es muy
importante apunta muy bueno porque en el
55 por ciento de la reducción de
emisiones que necesitamos para hacer
carbono neutral viene de que nos
cambiemos a la energía limpia pero el
otro 45% se puede obtener solo si
cambiamos la forma en que nosotros
construimos todas las personas a diario
y nos comportamos como nosotros tomamos
nuestras decisiones desde verdad como
utilizamos el transporte como
privilegiamos un transporte limpio que
no solamente es electro móvil sino que
utilizamos más el auto es el transporte
público utilizamos también verdad la
bicicleta etcétera como cambiamos
nosotros nuestro sistema de alimentación
hacia una alimentación más balanceada
como transformamos la manera en que
nosotros gestionamos nuestros residuos
cuánto podemos comportar casi un
hablamos en más del 50% de la bolsa de
basura que generamos diariamente en
nuestros hogares es de productos
orgánicos sino sobre la composta nos
reducimos todas esas emisiones que son
tremendamente contaminantes mucho mucho
de esta transformación la podemos hacer
a uno de nosotros en base a nuestros
hábitos diarias de vida ministra nos
queda un minuto y es fundamental
preguntar cuál es el aporte de américa
latina a toda esta situación cómo
aliviar esta catástrofe bueno américa
latina tiene mucho mucho por a verdad
porque si bien somos uno de los
continentes más afectados por el
calentamiento global la sequía los
huracanes los aluviones etcétera también
somos unos países que tienen una vida
diversidad más rica y naturaleza más
rica las soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza que no es nada más sencillo
para aplicar a la gente común y
corriente que utilizar los mismos medios
que la naturaleza nos ha entregado para
tener un desarrollo limpio nuestros
bosques que son los mayores mitigadores
del cambio climático que observen
justamente la los gases de efecto
invernadero si nosotros fort estamos
ampliamente si también nosotros
recuperamos nuestros espacios naturales
nuestros humedales si nosotros que
tenemos ésta
la biodiversidad aplicamos estas medidas
que son las más costosos pacientes para
combatir el cambio climático
latinoamérica fue puede ser un gran
pulmón del mundo que ayuda a combatir el
calentamiento global carolina schmidt
presidenta de la cob 25 y ministra para
el medio ambiente de chile gracias por
estar en france 24 y es todos ustedes
continúen con toda la programación de
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
y